deep in the Mounds of Switzerland lies
one of the oldest and most exclusive
boarding schools on the planets and this
school isn't just for rich people it's
not for the one percent no it's from the
point zero zero one percent this is
where billionaires and royalties send
their children to be educated it's even
known as a school of Kings for just how
prestigious and expensive it is former
students have included the Shah of Iran
Prince Rainier of Monaco King Albert II
of Belgium Winston Churchill's
grandchildren John Lennon's son Sean
Lennon even the Rockefeller Dupont and
Rothschild families went to school here
it costs 157 thousand dollars per year
to attend this all-powerful boarding
school which is around seventy thousand
dollars more than Harvard and what are
they getting for all this money not only
this the school has two campuses one
located in the Chateau to rosea state in
roll built in the 14th century and the
other campuses located in chalets and
the ski resort of gustad and teaching is
in English and French students observe
the culture and character of both
English and french-speaking ways of
thinking and in total Over 20 Languages
are taught at La Rose ensuring that
students also maintain contact with
their own culture at the heart of La
Rose is the Learning Center where the
library holds a collection of over
twenty thousand books in several
languages
group work classes and private study
allow students to gain increasing
autonomy in their academic work while
still providing the possibility of
Consulting teachers at any time all
students have their own laptop which
they use regularly in class and for
homework with an emphasis on the
importance of creativity the school has
a private Sailing Center on Lake Geneva
with its own 38-foot Yachts a fully
functioning stable with 30 horses of the
best breed in health in the winter
students are given full access to a
local ski resort in the gorgeous Swiss
Alps you get a five-star dinner prepared
by expert chefs every single night and
there's even a private spa for the
students to recharge after all their
hard work and yet most of you have never
even heard of this place before that's
because they've worked hard to stay out
of the spotlight and to keep their
billionaire school children hidden up in
the mountains because the truth is is
not the fancy amenities that keeps the
richest families in the world sending
their kids here it's because these
institutions systematically pump out
tomorrow's world leaders the people who
are going to control businesses
countries and us that's why the rich
Center kiss the
see in today's world if you work hard
and smart you can become successful from
nothing if you really wanted to you
don't need a degree from an average
University but these schools make no
mistake these schools do give Rich Kids
a very real unfair Advantage because
while you and me were conditioned for 12
plus years by plebeian teachers
surrounded by plebeian students for a
plebeian life these rich kids were
raised around power and wealth they got
to rub shoulders with the other rich and
Powerful they didn't get conditioned to
be laborers like we did they were
conditioned to take their rightful place
on the modern day throne and Lev Rose
isn't the only school out there there
are at least schools like this all over
the world pumping out tomorrow's rulers
stay dangerous and this is what the .001
doesn't want you to know
thank you
you can bet that these Elite schools are
giving kids a head start on AI but now
you too can get a head start on AI with
prompt perfect so prompt perfect is this
insane tool that helps you write better
props for chat gbt or even stable
diffusion or mid Journey so take this
prompt for example write an article
about Elon Musk creating SpaceX and
right down here chat GPD creates a very
average looking AI written article now
let's take the same prompt and put it
into prompt perfect as you can see it's
optimizing it right here for chat EBT
and this is a super optimized pump dot
prompt perfect outputted we went from
just 8 words to 99 words and right down
here you can see the before with the
original prompt and over here you can
see the much more thorough prompt and
the article that it generates is much
better as well but it's not just chat
gbt you can also do this with mid
Journey which is really cool so let's
take this prompt that someone made in
mid-journey and plug it into here to see
what we get so we got this prompt super
long now let's plug it into here and
boom we got this one and what I really
love about this is that I've spent like
an hour before fiddling with prompts in
mid-journing and I still can't get the
output I want but with this it saves you
a ton of time so give it a try with the
link below and use code jig for 15 offer
subscription and credit purchases that's
called Jake with the link below thanks
to prompt perfect for sponsoring this
video
getting into an elite boarding school
isn't easy even people with a few extra
million dollars to spend on their kids
education are fighting for the chance to
get in Le Rose accepts children as young
as seven years old but there are super
competitive admission rounds that
evaluate students on their intellectual
ability language skills character and
personality students are expected to
speak at least two languages and spoiled
anti-social or severely challenged
children will not be admitted to schools
like Lev Rose but let's get real here
it's less about how gifted you are and
more about who your parents are and how
much money they have in the bank these
are the kind of schools where people ask
who your parents are before they even
ask for your name so what should you
expect if you manage to prove yourself
and actually get into an elite school 8
30 a.m wake up in your perfect dorm room
with an in-suite bathroom which is
basically like your own Apartments
attend classes taught by some of the
brightest months in those disciplines
for a few hours each class will only
have a couple of students for every
teacher to ensure that you understand
everything are given the very best
education 12 30 PM spend the afternoon
connecting with your classmates from all
over the world we're talking about the
sons and Daughters of diplomats
presidents and Kings then go back to
class and learn about things like
entrepreneurship in multiple languages
3pm broaden your horizons by mastering
any sport you could ever think of in
professional fields and stadiums maybe
learn how to play an instrument at the
Juilliard level or take RR drama classes
that end up getting you onto Broadway 7
30 pm get ready for a restaurant quality
dinner prepared by only the best chefs
after eating a Tena on campus show or
lecture hang out with your rich kid
friends on the weekend maybe you'll be
taken on a cultural getaway or you'll
attend an important social events it's a
very strict life but luxurious plus it
leads to a resume that will buy you a
one-way ticket into any Elite College
around the world and then to the seats
of power of your choosing just like the
people it's already worked for
thank you
everyone has heard of Harvard and Yale
but nobody really knows about the
collection of elite schools where
Harvard and Yale get a lot of their
students from schools like the hurtwood
health school that's located inside a
mansion on 200 acres of land with a
budget of 125 000 for the Christmas
musical every year alone or leverage on
a school designed by Apple that is known
for turning kids as young as three into
Tech Geniuses and all these places have
an impressive list of former students to
back up their claims former Google CFO
Pietro dova and Princess Tatiana of
Greece and Denmark attended the lavish
iglon College in the Swiss mountains the
Vanderbilt family and the Saudi royal
family were both educated at the layson
American School the Lawrenceville school
is the alma mater for both billionaire
publisher Malcolm Forbes and former DCC
of Michael Eisner Prince Harry and
William the writer of the James Bond
series Ian Fleming and famous actors
Hugh Laurie and Eddie Redmayne all went
to Eton College in the UK and places
like the Rosenberg Institute have so
many powerful names coming through as
their policy to keep their list of
students a closely guarded seat Chris
it's insane just how many wealthy people
that influence your lives right now
attended these Elite boarding schools
and although there are plenty of
examples of very successful people
coming out from nothing without going to
a fancy boring school without going to a
fancy University the harsh reality is
that we have met people like this that
grew up around business that grew up
around wealth and there are so many
miles ahead of the masses that it's
almost unfair
wow
[Music]
where you went to school does matter to
an extent getting a degree from an
average University will set you up for
an average life but there's a reason why
Jeff Bezos Mark Zuckerberg Bill Gates
and many many more all went to the best
Ivy League schools and when it comes to
the lucky rich kids who were conditioned
from childhood to be successful well we
have actually met some of them and these
people are true business people way
better than me or anyone I know like to
them making money in business is as
natural as breathing air or riding a
bike because they weren't fed the wrong
conditioning their entire lives unlike
us first of all like about schools our
kids spend like first of all they sleep
eight hours right they wake up morning
they go to the school they spend there
like eight nine hours and we don't know
with who they spend time maybe these
teachers you don't even know what
they're thinking what they have on their
mind and you let them to give education
to your kids it's very dangerous visuals
if you not agree with these teachers on
your life position but you let them
teach your kids and when they become 16
you want they become like you this is
don't work it's heavy you have to
control who teach your kids and a lot of
people miss this a lot of crazy people
they're working in school too a lot of
and they give education to your kids but
if you talk one and one with them like
you're not gonna spend with them even
five minutes but they spent with your
kids eight hours every day whatever you
know it's like very dangerous things you
have to control this and let's face it
institutions like these Elite schools
ensure that the Bloodlines in power stay
in power the kids are the powerful are
put in a bubble when other kids of the
powerful to ensure that no plebs poison
their worldview while leaving nothing
but scruffs for the rest of the 99.99
there's an industry of evidence that
private schools help make our country
unequal only seven percent of the UK are
privately educated but a
disproportionate number occupies some of
the most influential job jobs but the
teaching profession is in turmoil the
wage gap between teachers and others
with the same level of education and
experience is nearly 20 and growing
the average public school teacher in
America earns a little over fifty
thousand dollars per year that's about
how much money the Rosenberg Institute
recommends parents give their kids as
spending money during one school year as
a state school teacher why would I not
want the absolute best for the young
people in front of me why don't they
deserve to have small class sizes
luxurious facilities access to this
incredible network of alumni and I think
that would make our society much better
and much fairer and abolishing private
schools is key to that in Finland they
did something interesting to combat this
they banned private schools entirely we
don't see education as an industry we
see education as a as a basic human
right for everybody and that's why all
education is free in Finland it's
against the law to run a private school
or private university now Finland has
ranked one of the best public education
systems out there and has one of the
smallest education gaps in the world and
what that means is that by making the
rich kids go to school with everyone
else
they grow up with those other kids as
friends
and when they become wealthy adults they
have to think twice before they screw
them over but let's face it the 0.001
are always going to want the best
education for their offspring so if it's
not Finland they will simply take their
money elsewhere so if you're not part of
the 0.001 what can you do then if you
weren't raised in these Elite schools
well the first thing is to be extremely
glad that you don't have Rich parents
because I've met a good amount of rich
kids by now and most of them are not
what we described here surely go to nice
schools share their parents buy them
nice or closed than you but deep down 99
of Rich guys have absolutely zero Drive
they're some of the most insecure people
I've met because they're living in the
shadows of their parents they have no
idea what they want to do what Their
Lives just like you but unlike you they
usually have zero hunger for 99 of kids
growing up with money completely screws
them up so that's the first step
recognizing that your weakness is
probably a strength the next step is to
recognize that you still need to take
all the stuff you've learned in public
school and University and throw it out
the window because the education system
for the masses exists for one thing and
one thing only to pop out hard-working
obedient thoughtless laborers and you
want to know who else sent their kid to
an elite private school the clintons ah
yes Bill and Hillary Clinton sent their
daughter Chelsea Clinton to an exclusive
K-12 school with a tuition of around 50
000 a year and you want to know what
else is interesting about the clintons
it's the in the span of around three
decades more than 50 people connected to
built and Hillary Clinton have died 50
people and these 50 people all magically
died in one of the three ways suicide
plane crash or robbery gone wrong just
those three and all these people all had
dirt on the cleanse that would have
ruined their political careers but now
they're conveniently dead and all these
deaths magically came to an end after
Clinton left the White House and we
expose it all in our new private
documentary The Clinton kill list that
you can watch right now by clicking the
card on the screen one member said now I
understand why you had to make these
videos member only thank you for your
hard work this YouTube membership is
where we post only the most damning
controversial documentaries that are too
spicy to be posted publicly so click the
card on the screen to watch now
[Music]
foreign